we also uh wish we could be at tonight's
award show with all of you sophisticated
people but daddy said and we quote I
don't want to spend a whole night that's
supposed to be about me and my greatness
listening to you two newly pubertized
buffoons
screaming where is Timothy chalamet
ER the speech is awesome thank you
really written by your daughters
absolutely not no no no they have no
idea that happened right there the last
now wasn't all just about the Sandman
the Gotham Awards represented part of
the industry that is a bit more gritty a
bit more artist Centric it's a good time
it's the empowerment award tonight's top
prize went to everything everywhere all
at once I can't believe that we're here
still no this movie came out in March
and people are still talking about the
movie it's every filmmaker's dream to
have their stuff seen by dismayed people
so we're we're over the moon and while
Steven Spielberg couldn't present
Michelle Williams with her tribute
because he tested positive for covid
Michelle made it a date night with her
bff Busy Phillips independent film gave
me my first real home in this business I
started making Independent films in my
20s and I continued to make them now
into my 40s there'll always be an
important part of my work